foreign billionaire Elon Musk is a
Restless entrepreneur
at 12 he did his first business deals
selling the code for a video game
at 32 he made around 180 million dollars
when PayPal was sold to eBay
before investing almost all of this in
electric car maker Tesla and Rocket
producer SpaceX SpaceX is trying to
ensure the long-term survival of
humanity with multiplayered species
multiple companies followed including
startup neurolink focused on merging the
human brain with computers
Elon Musk seems to be motivated by sort
of big problems that require him
personally to save the world whether
it's from climate change with electric
cars or whether it's from the risk of
human extinction and there's a sort of
Messiah complex to the whole thing
but where did this drive to save
Humanity come from
I did I did not have a sort of happy
childhood to be frank but I read a lot
of books I read lots and lots of books
science fiction inspired musk's ambition
to prolong the lifespan of humanity and
his business Empire
he's named several of his drone ships
which his Rockets land on after some of
the spaceships that appear in e m
Banks's novels
musk was at University in the 1990s when
there was a huge surge of interest in
existential risk that was quite a
formative influence it would seem on
Elon Musk human civilization could come
to an end for external reasons like
giant meteor or super volcanoes this
concern with existential risk kind of
joins up with Elon musk's Messiah
complex because by definition an
existential risk is a big a big problem
that needs to be solved so how do musk's
achievements measure up to his Ambitions
Tesla's impact on the core industry is
really astonishing electric cars had a
reputation for being you know rather
rubbish slow they didn't look cool they
started off by making a very very fast
sports car the Roadster which can out
accelerator for Rory or Lamborghini or
Maserati and suddenly that was a car
people wanted to drive successively
they've made more high volume and less
expensive cars
but the road to ramping up production
has been Rocky people have declared
Tesla you know about to go bust many
many times even if Tesla went bus
tomorrow it's very clear that it has
accelerated the transition to electric
vehicles
by 2040 it's estimated there will be
more than 700 million passenger electric
vehicles on the road
and about three quarters of all new car
sales will be fully electric
a big step in the right direction from
musk's efforts to help save the
environment
three two one zero but what about musk's
desire to save Humanity from extinction
by seeking out A Brave New World
would be happy if Humanity has a
self-sustaining City on Mars because
then the probable lifespan of humanity
is much greater he sounded completely
mad when he started talking about this
20 years ago but he's slowly getting
closer and closer to his goal
dollars in space location company
field
[Music]
musk is obviously a gambler and many
many times he has put all of his money
down and taken great risks many times
he's come very very close to losing it
all zero we're in stage one
the fourth rocket succeeded and spacex's
partly reusable Falcon 9 has slashed the
cost of space launches a vital step in
getting to Mars SpaceX absolutely
dominates the business of launching
stuff into orbit it's bigger than
everybody else in the industry put
together all the governments everybody
um it's it's phenomenal
if you're enjoying this film and want to
read more of our coverage why not take
out a subscription to The Economist
you'll receive daily and weekly analysis
of global Affairs you can read us online
in the app or listen to the audio
Edition
for the best offer click the link
spacex's satellite internet service
starlink has also allowed musk to play
Savior in a new way it's been critical
to Ukraine's Armed Forces
[Music]
they absolutely depend on it so that
they can coordinate their their
Communications of their troops they can
do things like use it to control drones
and see what's going on on the
battlefield so that in a strange way
gives Elon Musk an enormous amount of
power musk is also sort of setting rules
and limits on what can and can't be done
with this technology and thus what the
Ukrainian Army can and can't do
now he's taking on new Global challenges
having song how to make space flight
cheap and how to make electric cars sexy
he's decided that he can solve anything
and furthermore that those two big
engineering problems are a good template
for how he can solve other problems take
Free Speech musk bot Twitter now named X
in 2022 for a 44 billion dollars having
a public platform that is maximally
trusted and broadly inclusive
is extremely important to the future of
civilization how you manage a social
media platform that really isn't an
engineering problem when you're trying
to build an electric car or a rocket
your adversary as it were is the laws of
physics your adversary when it comes to
managing a social media platform is
human nature when he took over musk
immediately fired half of the workforce
giving remaining staff a choice
employees have until 5 pm today to
commit to extremely hardcore work or
leave the company
the self-declared Free Speech absolutist
has blocked tweets to prevent offense
making it harder for accounts to
impersonate big Brands when it was bad
for profits and blocked critics of
president erdogan during the Turkish
elections
he's had a sort of crash course in the
history and the philosophy of free
speech
users voted for him to step down as CEO
in December 2022
and he has now done so
but he still owns and controls the
company
he can boost one candidate over another
decide who gets blocked decide who gets
allowed to use Twitter and that's really
control of a giant political megaphone
now he's wading into geopolitics to try
to be a peacemaker
he tweeted a Russian friendly plan to
end the war with Ukraine
but musk's efforts in international
diplomacy might not be as altruistic as
they appear
you have to remember when he when he
talks about things like China Taiwan or
U.S China politics that he has enormous
vested interests in these things Tesla
has a large Factory in China and is
planning on building another
with the U.S and China were to go to war
and China were to seize foreign assets
within its borders that would all be
very bad for Elon Musk Elon Musk has
done very well out of his mission to
save Humanity
but perhaps sometimes he needs to
remember that with great power comes
great responsibility I don't think
there's any doubt that Elon Musk is a
figure of great you know World
historical importance he's changed the
trajectory of the car industry and of
space flight and he may yet change the
trajectory of other things too on the
other hand Elon Musk is one of these
people who seems to wield an enormous
amount of power and is extremely
unpredictable he changes his mind about
things very often that has serious
consequences
you know one of the big questions is
will the good that Elon Musk does
outweigh the bad
I'm Tom standage Deputy editor at The
Economist for more of our coverage of
Technology click the link thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
foreign
[Music]